today two updates and a vote for you
first I suggested it in the last video
but I'm announcing it here yes we're
going on an animated journey through the
history of writing it'll be fun and
honest to the concepts but it may take
its share of historical liberties to put
you into the role of the main character
I'm hoping that the resulting videos
will be watchable back-to-back as a
single story to an end to see how it all
pans out second a conundrum for some of
you the very first time we met was an
animated wonderment and then down the
line maybe that suggested older videos
with me lecturing at you other people
came in the other way looking for a good
information Duncan then got puzzled at
me wandering through a land of
linguistic curiosities this setting up
of expectations in marketing gets called
a brand promise what I'm worried about
is that this disconnect leaves some of
you disoriented it's like a broken brand
promise I don't have a solution for this
yet other than making you aware of this
change over time and refreshing old
thumbnails to make those old videos look
more like a back up library of resources
for us to draw on since the very
matchmaker that brings us together also
stacks me up against other channels
partly based on how many of my videos
you watch in a single sitting this
discontinuity on your viewing experience
can hurt me too
speaking of your viewing experience
which day of the week would you most
like to see me upload new videos still
Friday Tuesday a different day click to
vote for your favorite day and stick
around for a language